it's like you're going to uh Junior High
girls basketball team and you're a
full-grown adult or it's just you say
it's like competing against WNBA do you
think the average guy could beat a WNBA
girl of course I do
God
[Music]
all right how do we feel about this
there's a guy who entered an all women
poker tournament and he won the
tournament beating out 82 women damn
that's not that bad I don't even know
they had all women I'm pretty close to
the story because yeah Nikki's in the
community and [__]
I say that that's a sexist poker
tournament so as a as a as an official
poker wife who has a very prominent
professional poker player wife a husband
good intro yes she's a nice ass too he
he she has he has a nice asset what were
you told about The Insider part of it so
the thing about this that his you know
there's a couple things going on one
there's like a hack joke about it right
like hey I'm a guy but I like I
identifies the chicken I'm gonna be in
the poker tournament right so there's
like a hack joke about it where it's
like this guy who's like has a snowy
white beard looks like he's [__]
Santa Claus
he's playing in the Pokemon he's like 70
years old yes against women right so so
there's that going on right but then
there's a thing in the poker Community
amongst the women folk where they just
want to play poker sometimes and not
have to deal with dudes being dudes and
Bros being guys and guys highly
understandable yeah right and so so
there's like a a more welcoming
environment for a lot of those you gotta
deal with cat quality or stupid names
yeah yeah yeah yeah and just guys
weren't guys who will pots because
you're a chick which happens all the
[__] day long
but they could prey on that because and
they and some of them do Nikki does it
all the time I've never so like I know
like chess and others like stuff like
this right there's like oh there's girls
that don't really play in poker though
I've never really felt the same or heard
the same in the same kind of caliber of
like oh women like because there are
women that could [__] play like run
circles around them of course absolutely
but there still isn't a big winner
amongst the the chicks in the public
Community that's true which is just a
fact but state of fact but so like I'm
talking about like World Series of Poker
no woman has ever won yep right yep like
the the main event like a super
legendary Phil Ivy or yeah yeah but I
think that's just a statistical uh
disadvantage because there's less
entering there's less interest less
interest statistically way less it's
like now it's like less pool smaller
pool so so so but in the poker community
so there's this there's this offshoot of
women who just want to chill out now not
all of them do right like some women
don't care they want to go chop it up
with the dudes and they want to go beat
the dudes and they want to use their
advantages or disadvantages and like
kind of work the dudes in their own way
and figure out what their problems are
right like there are there's a lot of
women like that but there are some who
are newer to the game who just want to
play a friendly game and not have to
deal with being bullied on pots all the
time by [__] dudes who are dressed
maybe in a tracksuit like me and playing
aggressive you know wearing sunglasses
and [__] stone-faced and like they
just think all women are stupid and all
that kind of [__] right so that's what's
going on here is that these women feel
like they had their environment invaded
upon by this [__] dude who are who's
just like women can't win well if you
guys are so good why can't you win your
own tournament and all that kind of [__]
and they had to let him play too right
because he identified as a woman well it
says that there's a Florida law that you
can't discriminate against like another
like a guy that wants to play a women's
thing or something yeah so you think
this guy's like a cool guy to hang out
with
so it's not like a freaking unicorn
player went in and just just demolished
everybody's I don't know I don't know
enough to know but I just know that
that's like so coming in with like more
context than I probably would have had
if I wasn't married to a poker chick
yeah that this is what I'm hearing from
that end and that is cool though that
they just want to play and they don't
want to make it cool and Nikki Nikki is
super down with both sides like she's
like I am down with the chicks who just
don't want to have to deal with it and
they're usually newer poker players of
like older ladies who just want to chill
out a little bit casual players have a
fun time and there's a lot of group
environment too like with women like you
know women like sometimes they're like
you know especially in the poker
Community they're like let's get a group
and then go play poker and Nikki's very
like not that way Nikki's very like I
have my own thoughts about what I need
to do in my own system about how I need
to play and she puts the headphones in
and she just wants to focus on the game
but some chicks are like I want to go
with a pot of chicks so that I I'm more
strong like like against some of these
dudes who are kind of weird and
predatory against women sometimes so
they're going like a little pod they
feel safer and so I think that this guy
coming in made a lot of those women go
like great dude cool dude like you're
awesome you're funny like that kind of
yeah it does suck too that like when you
look at that like he beat out and 82
women it is kind of sad to think that
was 82 women that just wanted to have a
good time too yeah they all got together
and then they had to make it about him
yeah now he's the [__] story right
like for the whole day that does kind of
suck and there's a lot of mean words in
the poker Community who are like haha
we'll you know get better get good at
poker get good then women get good but
like well even if he didn't win the
whole thing it still kind of ruins the
intended Vibe 100 yeah I want to see if
he can win this consistently though
because in poker I mean you have stories
like Chris Moneymaker where just
absolute new wins a satellite and he
wins the World Series right so like
there's still variants tied to it yeah
it's this game of skill but it's not
like chess where it's purely a skill and
logic game so then like in that case too
like if you're if you're beating someone
by far like by distances that's a big
that's a big win in this case I don't
know how much he won and how
consistently he wins and if it's a
bragging thing like did he come in clear
82 within an hour like that's like oh
[__] like he's clearly a [__] boss
but if they gave you competition and you
barely won then it's like it's not
really bragging rights yeah and who was
the competition like like this
tournament wasn't like a bunch of
Cutthroats and
knowing that that makes a big difference
yeah and I didn't know that I did not
know that's like me going to a senior
citizen bingo hall and [__] them all
up and being like in your face Grandma
[__] which would be amazing though if
you like hella [__] up and bingo I
mean that's even like men are better to
decide it would literally be like me or
you in our dance Prime and going to a
local studio and just trying to smoke
everybody and they're not even they're
just dancing to dance yeah like that's
kind of like messed up to do yeah that
would feel very good for my ego I'm like
I should take part that is true because
it's not really like it's not like
you're going and competing against the
WNBA it's like you're going to uh Junior
High girls basketball team and you're a
full-grown adult and you're [__] them
up or it's just let's just say it's like
competing against the WNBA
do you think the average guy could beat
a WNBA girl of course I do yeah
God
so I'm able to go ball handle what's
that what's that by now is that a sex
Temple down am I sex tape laying down
now yeah yeah it would be
yeah but do you think there is any kind
of and that would suck if you've never
wanted to answer this for your whole
life but is there any kind of advantage
in the male mind in poker skill
I think that obviously like inherently
guys are more down to take risks which
is why Joe's saying statistically
there's less women poker players there
just is right like it's just look look
down the line like less uh deep sea like
um welders right less like um
um the guys who do the the lobster
whatever
yeah in poker their playing style is
different so like so like everyone has a
different playing style right right but
generally like
if they're good they understand how to
manipulate men
like they know they know the strengths
and weaknesses and they play on the
strengths and weaknesses versus like
guys might be way more willing to just
be
less calculated and risky or just pure
numbers calculated autistic and and not
even did you were saying it's [__]
annoying to play chick sometimes because
they they don't really Bluff they
probably have it
so they're too safe and that you could
see it she's like okay cool I have top
pair but like maybe they have the full
house because like they're betting into
it so they play too straight they played
straight up and yeah and she's like with
men they're more likely to be like
[__] wild balling some [__] like just
like [__] let's see interesting yeah
also like the the the winning
characteristics of a poker player is
like someone who's more interested in um
statistics math also high risk also uh a
bit Machiavellian because you have to be
okay with lying straight to the face of
your opponent and the key is being
disagreeable you're trying to take their
wall yeah because if you're an agreeable
player you want everyone to have a win
and a good time you're not going to win
you got to be able to smile at someone
and be like in this game I'm taking
everything for what you [__] got you
gotta be like thinking about the context
this is like an all women poker
tournament and then you got like Santa
Claus walking in yeah that might [__] up
everybody's game like he sits at your
table you're not really thinking about
your game as well much anymore you're
like man this is uncomfortable you know
what I mean like what is this or why is
he at this table and suddenly you're
just thrown off so it's probably just
more of an advantage for this guy yes
the adult at the all kids field trip
what the [__] is this [__] doing
here I saw this um I was at the wind
playing one time and I thought that this
girl was [__] genius right she comes
in clearly an escort low cut everything
she is flirting with every dude
everyone's giggling red face they're
super when a girl comes on the table you
guys act stupid right especially guys
that don't have like girlfriends or
relationships and then they want to act
even more whatever and then she started
identifying every single person's like
weaknesses and then she wasn't a good
card player but she was a person player
so guys would just give her pots like
you I was like I think he had a strong
car but he was letting her win and then
she would just be raking and raking and
raking and then she would like blow a
couple hundred dollars and she goes oops
well it looks like that's the end of the
night for me and some guys were like no
no just come stay stay no well you know
what here here have this and then guys
are like giving her money to play and
keep going and I'm like what the [__]
and at the end of the night she goes oh
that's enough for me and then she gets
up one of the guys pop up you go see him
going following her talking to her and
then they go up to the room together and
I'm like this girl came in not only
making money but she has a client and
I'm like see that's the that's how you
play these dudes and I was like that's
[__] genius yeah
message for all the women out there
that's how you play them she won in a
different way she didn't win that game
but she did
definitely that night with with probably
the most money out of all of us damn
[Music]